ALEX MAIER: Hello, and
welcome to the next episode
of Women Techmakers.
My name is Alex Maier, and
today with me in the studio,
I have Lynn Langit, who's a
friend and a GDE, a Google
Developer Expert.
So Lynn, tell me a
little bit about what
it means to you to be a GDE.
LYNN LANGIT: I'm a big
data and cloud architect.
So it really helps me to be
able to provide my customers
with timely access to
information about the Google
Cloud.
I work with customers to develop
usually proofs of concept,
because for a lot
of my customers,
the Google Cloud is a
new platform for them.
So we'll work side by
side and we'll usually
come up with a POC, so
that they can understand
the capabilities of Your Cloud.
ALEX MAIER: And how does it
usually go from there on?
LYNN LANGIT: Well, it depends.
You're not the only
cloud game in town.
So sometimes the
customers will find
that Your Cloud is the
best pick for them,
and sometimes somebody
else's will be.
ALEX MAIER: How has the
Google Cloud platform been
in your experience
for your business?
LYNN LANGIT: Well, the services
that my customers most often
used are App Engine.
And I work with the enterprise.
So I've got Java
customers most generally,
although I have had one Python
implementation that we're
going to talk a little bit
more about later in the show.
And then I've done
quite a lot of work
with BigQuery, because I
work in the big data area.
And I'm particularly
impressed with the breadth
of service offering
around BigQuery,
ALEX MAIER: Great.
So you also are an educator.
So what kind of courses or
other offerings do you develop?
LYNN LANGIT: Well, I've done
actually a number of things.
I wrote some courses for a
company called pluralsite.
And they're in-depth,
developer, video-based trainings
with code samples.
And I did those a couple
years ago on Google App
engine with Java to
get developers started.
And then I also did a series
on Google Compute Engine right
when it came out
of a trusted tester
and into general release.
And then I did a
series on BigQuery.
And what I've done recently--
I updated this in January,
because that series
was a couple of years
old-- is I made the
Google App Engine course
updated because App Engine
had some new features
and new capabilities.
And I put it out on
YouTube this time
for even broader audience reach.
ALEX MAIER: So if our
listeners and viewers wanted
to watch these videos,
where would they find them?
LYNN LANGIT: I have
a channel on YouTube.
It's under SoCalDevGal,
because I'm
based in Southern California.
And I have over 150 different
videos on cloud and big data
technologies.
ALEX MAIER: That is great.
Wow.
That is quite a bit.
I bet it took you a
lot of time to make.
LYNN LANGIT: Well,
some of the videos
are really short because one
of the things that I have found
is useful for people
is as I'm staying
relevant on these
new technologies,
I will actually just turn
on a screen capturing--
you know, Camtasia-- and
I'll just show people
what I'm studying and edit
out the bloopers and stuff.
But they like to see
what I'm looking at,
and it sometimes
saves them time.
ALEX MAIER: Yeah.
I bet that that's a
great thing to do.
So you mentioned that you
worked on the Python project.
And we have another
guest with us today--
Eric Grimm, software developer.
Hi, Eric.
ERIC GRIMM: Hi, how are you?
ALEX MAIER: I'm well.
How are you?
ERIC GRIMM: I'm good.
It's a little cold today,
but otherwise, it's nice.
ALEX MAIER: Yes, Eric is joining
us today from Long Island.
So nice to have you
on the show, Eric.
ERIC GRIMM: Thanks, I'm glad to.
ALEX MAIER: So Lynn and
Eric worked together
on a project which was
quite unusual in a few ways.
So can you tell us a little
bit more about it, Lynn.
LYNN LANGIT: Sure.
Well, I'll talk
first about how I
got brought in to the
project, and maybe Eric
will have some
insights that he wants
to share with the audience.
So Eric works for a PR company,
and as part of a project,
he was asked to create a
registration site on Google App
Engine.
And his background
is in ColdFusion.
And so the company reached out
to me as a developer expert
to help him as a new
developer on App Engine
to understand that platform.
So what we did, because I live
in greater Southern California,
is we did remote pairing.
In fact, this is the
first time I've actually
seen Eric's face, because we did
voice and we did screen shares.
And I helped him out,
understanding the APIs.
And it was kind of interesting,
because for both of us,
it was our first
time using Python.
And I actually, from my
perspective-- and Eric,
you certainly get
to weigh in here--
I thought the Python samples
were pretty usable and pretty
well written and
got us up and going.
So to that end, I
think it would probably
be interesting for the
audience to hear for you,
as a new Google App
Engine developer, what
your experience was
like-- honestly--
in getting an App
Engine set up and going.
And before you talk
about that, you
should also say
what the site's for,
because it's kind of a cool
thing that the site's for.
ERIC GRIMM: Sure.
Well, as Lynn mentioned, I
work for a promotions marketing
agency.
We basically deal with
sweepstakes and contests
and moderation tools,
things of that nature.
But we do a lot of registration
forms along the way.
We've done work with Google
and YouTube in the past.
And we were brought in
to work on this project.
It's called Call to Code.
It's a website for
students in Ireland.
The teachers will
register the students,
and. the students will take
part in an online coding
competition.
And the winners will move on
to an on-site competition,
again in Ireland.
Hopefully next year,
they'll roll it out a little
to a little wider audience.
But as she said, I do come
from a ColdFusion background.
We initially intended
to write the site
in cold fusion using
our SQL server database.
Google Security wanted us to
write it in Google App Engine.
So I chose Python as my language
of choice for the project.
It seemed to have a
lower barrier to entry
than trying to jump into Java
or something a little more
technically-oriented.
The samples on the
Google site were great.
They helped me get
up and running, up
to speed very quickly.
And Lynn was instrumental
along the way
in pointing me in the
right direction on quite
a few of the stumbling
blocks that came up.
LYNN LANGIT: So I
think it might be
interesting for the audience,
because I think a lot of people
are probably having a similar
background with traditional web
apps and relational
databases, to talk about some
of the things that
we talked about.
In particular, I think
we talked quite a lot
about the high
replication data store,
because that was
really a different data
model than the relational store.
And I think the
audience might benefit
from hearing what was the
most useful in getting you
up and going on the high
replication data store.
And any stumbling blocks
or anything, anything you
learned-- you know, that kind of
stuff would be useful for them.
ERIC GRIMM: Right.
Well, the high
replication data store
is definitely a
different paradigm
than a relational
database that I'm used to.
Some things that were very
easy to get along with
are the ability to
just add properties
to a particular entity
within the data store.
You can add as many
properties as you want,
but then you can end up
with some entities that
are missing
properties, which makes
it a little more difficult
to find if you're searching
on a particular field
piece of data, for example.
The fact that it's
high replication
means that sometimes it might
take a little while for objects
to be consistent across the
vast network of Google servers.
So we did run into a couple
issues where, for example,
a teacher would register
one of their students,
and the student wouldn't
show up immediately,
just because it
hadn't been replicated
all the way across
the data store.
But with a little
user education,
that wasn't an issue
that really brought
itself to bear in
the live application.
ALEX MAIER: So where are you
right now in this project?
Has it launched?
You're in beta, aren't you?
Or are you launched?
ERIC GRIMM: We ran
through a beta phase
where we had a few
select teachers
and a few select students
that use the site,
ran through some
practice contests,
and gave us some generally
positive feedback.
We are in the process of
gearing up for a wider launch.
There is an actual
coding competition
coming up on April 3 in Ireland.
We've had something along the
lines of 250 teachers that
are registered for the contest
that in turn registered
close to 800 students that will
be taking part in the contest
once it rolls out live.
ALEX MAIER: So
when do you expect
to have it rolled
out and all these 800
students to begin coding?
ERIC GRIMM: Again,
it's a timed contest.
There is a 24-hour
period for them to enter.
So on April 3 is when it
launches for the 24-hour period
that they will be able to
enter the competition itself.
ALEX MAIER: All right.
Well, good luck
with that, and I'm
keeping our fingers
crossed for you.
ERIC GRIMM: Oh,
thank you, thank you.
ALEX MAIER: So, Lynn, can
you share a little bit
about the experience, coding,
pairing up with somebody
all the way across
the continent.
LYNN LANGIT: Well, just
generally, I pair-program.
And I'll do in person when I
can, but I also remote pair.
I think for Eric, it was
new, the pair-program.
ERIC GRIMM: Yes, it was.
LYNN LANGIT: Yeah, and
maybe a little skeptical
in the beginning, maybe?
Maybe?
What once we got, for
example, a couple modules up
and going, it was a little
bit more fun to do, I guess.
But, yeah, I thought
it was pretty cool.
I was a little bit apprehensive
to dig into the Python,
because my expertise is
Java, and this is literally
the first time I did
anything in Python.
But again, kudos to you
guys and good samples.
Seriously, god samples matter.
They really, really matter.
And I guess that's
my ask back out
to the Google people
who are watching this.
Anything that you're
making for any platform,
but my world is the cloud,
make sure your samples
are rock solid.
Because it really
matters, I mean,
it allowed you to hit your
deadline, Eric, I think.
ERIC GRIMM: Absolutely.
ALEX MAIER: Well, great.
So Lynn, there's another
project that you're working on.
It's a nonprofit?
LYNN LANGIT: There is.
Yeah, I'm the co-founder of a
nonprofit called Teaching Kids
Programming.
And really there's
two aspects that I
wanted to share with
the audience here.
First of all, we actually
use Google App Engine
as part of the solution.
What it is it's a set of
free and open source course
where it introduced children
ages 10 and up to programming
in Java.
Which some people
might say, Java?
Well, that's not
a modern language.
But that is the language,
if there is one.
that's offered at high schools
for Advanced Placement.
So we had a lot of
requests for on-ramping.
So that's why we
created the course wear.
It's up on Github.
The connection to
Google App Engine
is that it kind of looks
like Logo, the basic recipes.
So it's got the turtle
drawing the squares and stuff.
And so when the kids
execute the program,
it sends the blog up
to Google App Engine.
And this is actually the reason
I got into the Google Cloud way
back, when because it was
easy to use, and you guys
have had a generous free tier.
And we still use it today.
And it's a great way to get
started on the Google Cloud
if you've a nonprofit project.
So I wanted to share that.
ALEX MAIER: Great,
thank you so much, Lynn.
LYNN LANGIT: Thank you.
This was another episode
of Women Techmakers.
my name is Alex Maier.
Good bye.